you got like a power couple then cuz you
guys are both talent I love him so much
is your favorite power couple you guys
but for real though
but like aside from us like there
everybody has a face I'm not we're not
that powerful baby let's see I know but
can I say this yeah I'm not [ __ ]
kidding you when I go on the road now
right
where's kalila boom pow every [ __ ]
night
30 times a night worse kalila where's
Claude did she come did she come to you
come so in my opinion you are a park we
are just like to infiltrate your
identity so like the next girl after me
we'll always have to deal with that
something I love that I get you what do
you mean by that I just need her to
struggle past like the association
between lately I will always have with
you like she can never be tiger belly
she's gonna hate the fact that we did
hundreds of episodes together yeah and
then everyone will always associate the
both of us
I never had to deal with that with you
you've only dated girls like for one
year at a time we've been together for
years
it's you've met my other girlfriends I
have I ever actually met them but I just
know that it was not this long yeah yeah
this is it's over three years now yeah
over three yeah do you think would be
the parents yeah God you guys are easy
animals yeah before too many oh but do
you do you feel do you understand what
I'm saying though where it's like you
don't want the next girl yeah you
definitely want to mark your territory
like in every way possible you also want
to make sure that the past girlfriends
don't have any like you know they don't
exist anymore I was dating when I moved
in with Dave and he in his old
girlfriend had lived there before and
this was like I was really hard for me
to handle and I remember like when I
moved in and I was going through she had
like these jars of beans and I just
remember like burning them I just hid
away but I was like I would always call
her the old witch I'm like the old witch
is gone Wow yeah I just women do that we
do that I mean I'm also the very
possessive clingy jealous obsessively
I'm just that person are you I don't
know if I'm very needy yeah I don't know
I think that I had to all the things you
want in a girl I was all you can't be
that way with him I think that yet he's
so he has an aversion to that type of
like clinging there's no way to be
clinging with Bobby right so in the
beginning I was a little bit I didn't
know how to be around him I was very
uneasy and who what I stood would I who
I was to him and I think it caused a lot
of problems early on but as soon as I
realize like look dude like you can't
chase him he's gonna be the animal that
he is and I mean I could not even talk
to him about little things I would find
in this house like whether it was
photographs of him like spreading a
woman's ass cheeks open like I mean they
were I just had to like toughen my own
skin it was really weird cuz it was so
many I mean I still keep them because I
can't even throw them away cuz it's like
yeah it is proof that it happened you
threw away that little dollhouse right
well the dollhouse was bad juju what I
would put like he had this weird little
pink dollhouse that always made me feel
Sera's oh that's why I didn't even know
was hurt no sir I don't dislike her I
think she's a girl
but Sarah's doll house was here and it
was gone the only reason I got rid of it
is because it had a creepy vibe to it
like something lived inside of it so it
had little windows I would cover with
little index cards yeah because she used
to go to like first stores and buy these
like weird [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah actually
I mean you guys yeah but she does have a
jacket of mine but I can never ask it
for about but I want it back because
it's like it's weird like a [ __ ] lion
in the back it's a green military jacket
with a gigantic lion roars I wear it no
I look Qi words at The Comedy Store PO I
saw yesterday mm-hmm
yeah man
yeah you do do you know Sarah Hyland not
the girl from Modern Family but that
yeah yeah yeah she's to get back there
now on Sundays she's a friend you know
it's cool yeah yeah that is sorry I
threw her dollhouse I didn't even know
his hers [ __ ] the dollhouse why did you
even bring it up I feel bad he's won
reward wall yet a spirit living inside
it spirit
[Music]